[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich los fluidos
supercríticos
la materia puede existir en diferentes
estados a diario en la tierra
encontramos tres estados de la materia
sólido líquido y gaseoso
cada una de estas Tres formas
corresponde a una configuración
microscópica en un sólido las moléculas
están fijadas entre sí presentan una
estructura uniforme ya que están
fuertemente ligadas en un líquido las
moléculas están más sueltas son libres
de moverse pero guardan una cierta
cohesión al ser un fluido un líquido
puede deformarse pero conserva un cierto
volumen esto contrasta con los gases en
los que las moléculas son totalmente
libres de moverse y pueden llegar a
ocupar todo el volumen en el que están
contenidas
según la temperatura y la presión del
entorno un cuerpo se encontrará
naturalmente en uno de estos tres
estados
a la presión atmosférica el agua es
naturalmente líquida entre 0 y 100
grados Celsius tales son las condiciones
de nuestra atmósfera en la tierra lo que
explica que se puede encontrar agua
líquida en el planeta
[Música]
si la temperatura de la atmósfera fuera
en promedio de 200 grados Celsius el
agua se encontraría en forma de gas de
vapor de agua
para representar las condiciones
necesarias a la presencia de los tres
estados de la materia podemos dibujar un
diagrama de fases
dicho diagrama representa la fase del
agua el estado en el que se encuentra de
forma natural para diferentes valores de
presión y temperatura
Comencemos tomando un recipiente
hermético dentro del cual vertemos agua
la temperatura en su interior puede
ajustarse al calentarlo o enfriarlo y la
presión puede modificarse empujando
tirando de un pistón
para completar el diagrama utilizaremos
tres colores
escogemos el gris para el gas
el azul claro para el líquido y el azul
oscuro para el sólido
cada punto del diagrama corresponde a
una combinación única de temperatura
presión que reproduciremos en el
interior del recipiente
una vez elegidos los valores podemos
observar En qué fase se encuentra el
agua dentro del recipiente y pintar un
pequeño recuadro en el diagrama con el
color correspondiente
repitiendo este proceso con múltiples
valores obtenemos finalmente un mapa en
el que aparecen tres zonas
ahora bien si un cierto binomio presión
temperatura se encuentra dentro de una
de estas zonas por ejemplo la zona azul
oscuro significa que bajo estas
condiciones específicas el agua se
encuentra naturalmente en estado sólido
algo que llama la atención es el hecho
de que las tres zonas tienen fronteras
precisas
cuando nos situamos en la frontera entre
dos zonas los dos estados a cada uno de
sus lados pueden coexistir
simultáneamente de forma estable por
ejemplo cuando calentamos un cubo de
hielo bajo la presión atmosférica se
desplaza gradualmente hacia la derecha
del diagrama a medida que aumenta su
temperatura
Cuando llegamos al límite de la zona
sólida a una temperatura de 0 grados
Aparecen las primeras gotas de agua
líquida
poco a poco el cubo de hielo se derrite
permaneciendo a la misma temperatura la
energía suministrada a través del calor
Ya no modifica su temperatura sino que
provoca que se derrita es decir que
reordene sus moléculas a escala
microscópica
una vez que la transición haya concluido
su temperatura comenzará a subir de
nuevo Lo que significa un movimiento
hacia la zona del diagrama
correspondiente al estado líquido hemos
realizado lo que se llama una transición
de fase pasando de un estado de la
materia a otro al cruzar una de estas
fronteras
[Música]
Otro aspecto que merece mencionarse es
que existe un punto en el que las tres
zonas se tocan se trata de un punto de
contacto entre cada uno de los posibles
estados de la materia sólido líquido y
gas bajo estas condiciones específicas
de temperatura y presión es entonces
posible que el agua coexista en forma
sólida líquida y gaseosa todo al mismo
tiempo este peculiar escenario se
denomina punto triple para el agua este
punto triple corresponde a una presión
del 0.6% de la atmósfera y a una
temperatura de una centésima de grados
Celsius son condiciones que no se dan de
forma natural en la tierra pero que
podemos crear en un laboratorio lo que
nos permite hervir de forma sorprendente
el agua mientras que una parte de ella
está congelada
volviendo al diagrama de fases lo que
más nos interesa es que la línea que
separa el líquido del gas parece
detenerse repentinamente
[Música]
este punto específico en el que la curva
se detiene se denomina punto crítico
corresponde a una combinación de
temperatura y presión muy elevadas que
no se dan de forma natural en la tierra
pero que pueden Igualmente ser
reproducidas en un laboratorio
tomemos entonces nuestro recipiente de
agua y ajustemos su presión y
temperatura para que se sitúe a lo largo
de esta línea
como hemos visto en la frontera entre
las dos zonas el agua aparece
simultáneamente en dos estados
diferentes en este caso líquido y gas
cuando miramos dentro del recipiente
vemos una separación entre el agua
líquida y el vapor de agua
ahora calentemos si comprimamos
progresivamente el recipiente de tal
forma que nos acerquemos al punto
crítico sin salirnos de la línea
al aumentar la presión las moléculas de
agua del gas se comprimen fuertemente
se acercan y ocupan menos espacio el
vapor se vuelve más denso
[Música]
por otro lado el aumento de la
temperatura obliga a las moléculas del
líquido a vibrar cada vez más de este
modo las moléculas están menos ligadas
entre sí y su creciente agitación hace
que ocupen más espacio
el agua líquida se vuelve menos densa
progresivamente la separación entre el
líquido y el vapor se hace cada vez
menos visible
de repente la densidad de líquido que
disminuye y la del gas que aumenta
alcanzan el mismo valor
a partir de ese momento las dos fases ya
no son distinguibles el líquido y el gas
en el recipiente tienen exactamente la
misma densidad obtenemos una especie de
mezcla homogénea de líquido y gas hemos
alcanzado el punto crítico Más allá de
este punto es imposible distinguir el
gas y el líquido las dos fases se han
fusionado en una sola el estado de esta
agua no es ni líquido ni gaseoso su
comportamiento es bastante similar al de
un gas pero también presenta
interesantes propiedades que suelen
atribuirse a los líquidos
a este estado se le denomina fluido
supercrítico
es curioso constatar que a diferencia
del Estado sólido el líquido del gas no
son independientes Aunque es posible
pasar de líquido a gas mediante una
transición por ejemplo hirviendo el agua
también es posible hacerlo sin ninguna
transición de este tipo
basta con ajustar la temperatura y la
presión en nuestro recipiente para
esquivar la frontera entre los dos
estados
comenzamos con un líquido y al
convertirlo en un fluido supercrítico
podemos transformarlo en un gas
este experimento es impresionante al
observarlo es muy poco habitual
presenciar como un líquido se convierte
en un gas sin ninguna transición visible
volviendo al fluido supercrítico es
posible observar un fenómeno
sorprendente a medida que nos acercamos
al punto crítico cuando el fluido
alcanza este punto empieza
espontáneamente a dispersar la luz a
esto se le llama opalescencia crítica
se debe la refracción de la luz dentro
del fluido Los Rayos de Luz se
ralentizan en función de la densidad del
fluido
al acercarse al punto crítico el fluido
tendrá que dividirse en líquido de gas
pero justo antes de que esto ocurra
vacila entre uno y otro estado
estas indecisiones dentro del fluido
provocan fuertes fluctuaciones de
densidad que dispersan la luz de la
misma manera que nuestra atmósfera
dispersa la luz del sol dando al cielo
su color
en lo cotidiano los fluidos
supercríticos tienen muchas aplicaciones
sus propiedades son muy interesantes
aunque se comporten principalmente como
un gas podemos utilizarlos como
disolventes pueden servir para extraer
determinadas sustancias
el dióxido de carbono supercrítico se
utiliza ampliamente para extraer aromas
de las plantas la nicotina del tabaco o
incluso la cafeína del café una de las
principales ventajas del co2
supercrítico es que a diferencia de los
disolventes líquidos no es tóxico y es
relativamente fácil de utilizar con un
poder de extracción muy elevado
en su forma supercrítica el agua también
es muy buen disolvente sirve para
destruir residuos orgánicos sin liberar
gases nocivos en lugar de quemarlos
los fluidos supercríticos tienen
múltiples y diversas aplicaciones
prácticas como la producción de
combustible la refrigeración o incluso
la protección microbiana
para concluir el fluido supercrítico es
un estado de la materia en sí mismo
por encima de un determinado punto de
presión y temperatura el líquido del gas
parece no fusionarse formando un único
estado homogéneo con propiedades tanto
de gas como de líquido
en la tierra la temperatura y la presión
son demasiado Bajas para que tales
fluidos puedan existir de forma natural
sólo se pueden encontrar pequeñas
cantidades en el fondo del océano dentro
de las fuentes hidrotermales donde la
temperatura y la presión son extremas
aunque son escasos en la tierra los
fluidos supercríticos son relativamente
comunes en el universo especialmente en
el interior de los planetas gaseosos
dentro de sus atmósferas las condiciones
son tan extremas que algunas capas son
en realidad supercríticas
así la espesa atmósfera de Venus puede
alcanzar los 500 grados celsius y una
presión 100 veces superior a la de la
Tierra
en tales condiciones su atmósfera
compuesta principalmente por dióxido de
carbono es un fluido supercrítico
[Música]